hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll long
time listeners will know that one of the
topics I'm very interested in here on
the podcast is thinking rationality how
human beings cogitate to make decisions
about the world and even longer term
listeners will know that I love using
the game of poker as a model for
thinking about human rationality of
course poker is a very finite
well-defined game you know what the
rules are you know what the rewards are
but it models a lot of the circumstances
that are very important when we're
making hard decisions in our everyday
lives poker is a game of incomplete
information we don't know what our
opponents have it's a game where there's
randomness involved you don't know what
the next card is going to be it's a game
where there probably is a strategy which
will at least guarantee you won't lose
over the long term but you might not
know what that strategy is you have to
be a good Bayesian you have to do your
best to model your other opponents etc
and perhaps most of all poker is a game
where even if you know cognitively
consciously what the best strategy is
sometimes it can be hard to obey to
follow that best strategy you can be
what in poker terms is called on tilt
your emotions can get in the way and
your rationality can suffer thereby so
the perfect person to talk about all
these ideas with is Maria konnikova
today's guest Maria got her PhD in
psychology at Columbia University
starting with Walter Mitchell who was a
very famous for the marshmallow test you
know when you give a small child a
marshmallow and ask them if they can
avoid eating it while you step out of
the room and the claim is that whether
or not the kids can avoid just eating
the marshmallow predicts success later
in life but Maria decided not to go the
academic route instead becoming a writer
and she became a very successful staff
writer at The New Yorker and then
decided that what she really needed to
do was up her rationality game and the
best way to do that was to learn to play
poker and not because she was a poker
hobbyist she literally as she says
didn't know how many cards there were in
the deck but on the basis of her
psychology degree and her work as a
writer she managed to convince Erik
Seidel who is one of the world's leading
poker players
to coach her with the idea that she
would get good enough to play in the
World Series of Poker turns out she did
way better than that not only did she
appear in the World Series she's won
hundreds of thousands of dollars playing
poker joined Team PokerStars as a poker
ambassador and has been very successful
overall in the tournament circuit all of
the story is told and the lessons for
rationality psychology and human life
are summarized in her new book the
biggest bluff how I learned to pay
attention master myself and win I think
that this podcast is not about poker
really we use poker as an example but
it's not teaching you how to play poker
you're not going to learn how frequently
to 3bet or whether you should worry
about getting cheque raised or anything
like that it's about human beings how
they think how they reason and in the
laboratory of playing poker so you'll
learn a lot about human beings maybe
even be inspired to go play a few hands
of poker while you're at it don't forget
there's plenty going on if you want to
go beyond just listening to the podcast
you're welcome to visit the website for
Posterous Universe comm slash podcast
where every podcast has show notes links
to people's books and also full
transcripts of the podcast you can also
support the podcast on patreon you go to
patreon.com/scishow on em Carole and in
return for pledging a dollar or two
dollars per episode of the podcast you
get to listen to the episodes ad free
and you also get to ask questions every
month as part of a monthly ask me
anything so there's a lot going on there
in quarantine during lockdown here
involved with the mindscape podcast I
hope that this podcast is doing it's
tiny little part to keep us all sane and
distracted from what's going on all
around us and with that let's go
[Music]
Maria konnikova welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so much for having me
Sean so I guess the obvious question is
you have a PhD in psychology you have a
staff writer job at one of the most
prestigious publications in the world
what is it that inspired you to say to
yourself you know what I really want to
do is to play poker at a high level this
was not something I had ever seen coming
and had you asked me you know five years
ago will you ever be a professional
poker player will you ever be playing
poker at on any level whatsoever my
answer would have been ha ha ha because
it's not it's not a lifelong passion of
mine it's not like I've been you know
poker player from childhood playing with
my friends playing with my family which
a lot of professional poker players did
do by the way if you look at a lot of
their stories you see that they started
when they worried absurdly young that's
not my case what brought me to poker was
actually just a completely tangential
direction my last book had come out the
confidence game and it was doing well I
was doing a lot of media for the book
everything was great and then a few
months after the book came out a lot of
things just all of a sudden went wrong
all at once I had a major health problem
that has still not been diagnosed it was
some sort of autoimmune thing where all
of my hormones just went completely out
of whack and I became allergic to just
everything like I couldn't wear clothes
basically and yeah it was it was pretty
bad my body would just break out in
hives randomly I visited all these
specialists no one knew what was going
on and this lasted for quite some time I
was just on these horse doses of
steroids and eventually it went away but
to this day we have no idea what
happened then my grandmother died and it
was very sudden just a total freak
accident my mom lost her job my husband
lost his job just all of these things
happening one after the other after the
other and none of them are things that
we really have any
control over and it really made me just
pause and start questioning you know
what what do we really control and what
role does chance play in everyday life
and I decided that that's what I wanted
to write about that I wanted to do a
book about this but as you know you know
you've written books that's not really a
topic for a book right you know that's
just some fear and inquiry into chant
the nature of chance and I'm not you
know I'm not chopping our I'm not I'm
not gonna do a philosophical treatise so
I started reading about chance and
someone said hey you know you're
interested in chance you should check
out game theory because that's actually
a way to look at chance in a really
organized way so I started reading John
von neumann's theory of games John von
Neumann is the father of game theory and
learned that he was not just a poker
player but that poker was the
inspiration for game theory and that
mondawmin very strongly believed that
poker was strategically a really
wonderful match for strategic
decision-making in life in general as a
game of incomplete information and it
was the game that most fascinated him
because he didn't really love chess he
thought that it was boring because
ultimately it was very solvable there
was always a right movement a wrong
movement and he didn't like gambling you
know he hated casino games like roulette
etc because not solvable at all it's
just gambling but poker he felt was kind
of in-between where you had incomplete
information but you could very
strategically make good decisions but
all the while there was never you know
there wasn't quite a solution so he said
I'm gonna solve this I started becoming
fascinated by you know what is this
poker thing why is it why did someone as
brilliant as Mon Norman think that this
held the key to so much and so I started
reading about poker and some light went
off and that brought me to the biggest
Bluff I decided you know what this is
going to be the book I'm gonna learn to
play poker I'm getting
someone really good to coach me I'm
gonna immerse myself in it and we'll see
what happens and of course I could never
have predicted that I would have
actually become good and gone pro that
was not part of the plan it was supposed
to be just a one-year immersion and it
went in a very different direction and
not only did you come from not having
grown up playing poker but you literally
according to the book anyway didn't know
how many cards were in the deck oh that
that is that is true that is a true
story I am in my first meeting with Eric
Seidel who's one of the best players in
the world and became my coach my mentor
and now is that just a good friend we
met over breakfast and you know he was
very hesitant because he doesn't coach
people he's never coached people before
and what intrigued him was that I wasn't
a poker player coming into him looking
to get better I was someone with a clean
slate and he realized just how clean
when I said well I know some things like
I know that you know there are 54 cards
in the deck and he just kind of looked
at me and I said what did I say
something wrong and to this day he will
not let me live that down and he just
jokes over and over he says you know one
day those Joker's will jump out of the
deck there are 52 cards in the deck for
those ability and members were not
themselves poker players or card players
yeah the Joker's The Joker's don't count
but yeah I mean I've heard also the
story of fun Newman one of the great
mathematicians and physicists of the
20th century right and his his interest
in mixed games and the balance between
randomness and control but so but your
interest I guess at the time at least at
the beginning was like you said not to
become the world's best poker player but
to sort of think of poker as teaching
you something about life more generally
is that safe to say yes that's exactly
right
I wanted to use poker as a kind of
metaphor for life to really think
through you know how how do we figure
out what that line is between what we
can control the decisions we can control
and the things we can't you know the the
cards the outcome the other players kind
of
that we don't necessarily have direct
control over as time went on I actually
realized that in some ways poker wasn't
much better metaphor for life than I
could have ever imagined
and that it was also perfect a learning
laboratory because I came from an
academic background I have a PhD not
just in psychology but I studied the
psychology of decision-making
specifically under conditions of risk
and uncertainty which is very similar to
a poker environment but you know what we
do as psychologists as we identify all
these problems all the ways that people
screw up when they're making decisions
the ways that they're irrational but
there aren't that many solutions I mean
even someone like Danny Kahneman who
want to know about price for his work in
this and you know if anyone knows
decision biases its Kahneman but even he
acknowledges that he still exhibits a
lot of the same bias you know that it's
really really hard to fight them and as
I started playing poker I had this
lightbulb moment when I realized this is
actually a perfect way to work through
these biases and emerge on the other
side a better less biased decision-maker
because poker actually forces you to
sample probabilities over and over and
over and you get to learn you know what
does 2% feel like what does 10% feel
like you get to learn all these things
that in day-to-day life we never get to
experience and so it makes you it forces
you to be more precise in your thinking
and it does so you know in an
environment that's controlled you know
it's not life life is messy life is
noisy there's noisy feedback you can
always you know say oh it's not my fault
that's the fault of this or that and
poker is much cleaner because it's a
game it's simpler and so you can
actually work through a lot of these
kinks and what I found as I started
playing was that all of a sudden I was
making better decisions away from the
poker table even when my poker plague
was still not very good well I thought
was very interesting near the end of the
book you mentioned that Nassim Taleb of
Black Swan Fame thinks that the kind of
thing you're doing
by learning poker and imagining you can
apply it to real life is not a good idea
because he thinks that the games are too
simple to model reality absolutely he
calls it the logic fallacy and he says
you know don't do this it's a fallacy
and you know whenever you havenõt seem
to live fella so you have to kind of
start saying oh oh my doing something
wrong
and I I think that he's absolutely right
that poker is too simple it's not life
but I think that that's where its
strength lies because you can test out
so much without the fear of the worst
possible outcome right because the worst
possible outcome in poker is that you go
broke it again you know for if you're
playing cash however much you bought in
for that you lose it all if you're a
crazy gambler you know you might
actually go broke but probably unless
you're involved with some shady elements
you're not going to die yeah hopefully
we hope and you know there are there's
only so much that can happen it's not
like life where anything can happen at
any given moment and so I think that
that frees you up to explore to actually
explore different elements of how you
can be you can learn you know what does
it feel like to be more aggressive what
does it feel like to do this you can
experiment you can kind of play around
with that you can play around with
different decisions and you can see the
immediate feedback in a way that you
don't often get a chance to see in life
so I think the simplicity actually makes
it a much more powerful teaching tool
and one that ultimately can be
incredibly applicable to life because of
the fact that it's stripped from a lot
of those externalities that we
experience in any other situation that
is messy I mean I totally agree with
Talib that life is messy that a game
can't model it perfectly but I just
don't see that as a drawback I see it as
a strength ya know as a physicist I'm
completely on your side in this
difference because of course you look at
simplified spherical cow models to get
sort of and I feel a feeling for the
basics and then you can try to tweak it
and try to apply it to the messy real
world and
the thing that fascinates people about
poker is just like fun oi Minh would
have said it's it's in that balance
region where there is randomness you
just can't help it you can do everything
right and lose terribly the variance is
large but it's also clearly skill right
and you can see that well there's
certain people who keep appearing at the
winner's circle in these tables
absolutely absolutely and the way that I
actually explain to people who think oh
so no you know you're you're a gambler
and I say no I'm not a gambler I'm a
poker player it's two very different
things in poker is a game of skill and
the way that I explain the difference
between kind of gambling even like
blackjack where you can have you know a
mathematical edge but you're still
gambling and poker is that in poker I
can have the best hand and lose and I
can have the worst hand and win and
that's a very skillful element and in no
other game in the casino is that the
case and so that to me is just the
epitome of skill and sure in the short
term you know luck is huge I could sit
down you know with the best player in
the world and beat him and that's not
because I'm suddenly the best player in
the world it's because I got very very
lucky but if that same player and I were
to play together for a hundred hours you
know a thousand hours 10,000 hours the
longer the horizon the more clear it
becomes that they are the better player
I won't get lucky over the long term the
variance is going to kind of catch up
with me yeah and I think that I like the
example that you give that human beings
are bad at randomness we should talk we
should talk a lot about the different
biases that people have because we make
mistakes and trying to be rational all
the time and poker does sort of make us
face up to them but one of them is this
difficulty in understanding what 2
percent means like you said I mean I
remember even in the last election when
people like Nate Silver were saying
Donald Trump has a 30% chance of winning
and then he won and people said well you
see he was wrong because there's 70%
chance that that Clinton was going to
win but thirty percent chances happen
all the time I mean even 2% chance
happen all the time absolutely it's huge
it's huge
I mean people gave Nate so much crap for
that and I wanted to say guys look at
how good his model was I mean 30% that's
enormous
I mean 30% is just I mean it's it's a
hop skip and a jump from 30 to 55 from
and and people just I think one of the
other things that poker has really
taught me is that is to be more
comfortable with uncertainty because the
human mind this is something that you
know I've talked about a lot it's
something that as a psychologist I focus
on a lot the human mind just hates
uncertainty we're very averse to it we
like to resolve it we don't like to be
in this you know gray world we like
black and white we like yes and no we
like to put labels on things you know we
we like to be sure of something it's
funny because my last book was about con
artists and the way that con artists
often get people to fall for what
they're selling is they give them
certainty they give them actually a
story that makes sense they give them
explanations that make sense when people
want them they tell them what they want
to hear and that's just not the way the
world works uncertainty is a huge part
of everyday life and we never know
everything and poker just if you're
going to be good at poker you have to
become comfortable in the world of
uncertainty you have to become
comfortable knowing that you're never
going to have all of the information and
that can be you know that's a scary
thing that's a scary proposition in a
lot of ways and I mean probably you're
well aware of this from your psychology
background but one of the things human
beings like to do is after the fact they
will come up with the story to why that
thing had to happen right if whatever
happened was just sort of predestined
and it's hard to just say well that's
the way the cookie crumbles that
particular time absolutely absolutely we
have so much hindsight bias in the way
that we analyze information that when
one of the things that I learned while
playing poker that I've been applied to
other areas
life that I really just encourage people
to do if they want to make better
decisions it's keep track of your
thinking in the moment so that you have
a tool to protect yourself against
hindsight bias so you know when for
instance when I'm playing and I know
that I'm going to have to talk through a
hand with my coach I think through my
rationale you know I'm raising here
because X Y & Z and I have to keep that
in mind
it not only forces me to slow down and
actually think through this decision and
be reflective about it rather than
reflects them about it and just do it
because oh this seems like a good place
to bet but then it also gives me
something to go back to and say did I
make the decision for the right reason
because if the decision worked out it's
so easy to say yeah of course I made it
over the rightness the right reasons and
it's so powerful to do that because in
life we so often just say oh well I knew
that but I did it because of bla bla bla
and you didn't know that right you're
actually rewriting history all the times
yep if you like learning new things and
who doesn't you might want to check out
the great courses plus a streaming
service that offers you courses from the
great courses these are sort of
introductory college-level courses from
some of the best professors in the world
on a wide variety of topics I've taught
some on physics on time the Higgs boson
dark matter and dark energy but there's
also courses on history on literature on
hobbies like playing the guitar for
example if you're enjoying today's
episode you might be interested in the
psychology of human behavior which is a
full 36 lecture course offered by
Professor David Martin which takes you
from the beginning of psychology through
modern research methods up to some of
the things that psychologists have
learned the great courses plus is
extremely convenient there's a dedicated
app so you can watch anywhere from your
mobile device but you can also sit in
the living room with your family and
friends and share a course together you
can toggle over to your phone while
cooking dinner so don't wait any longer
now is the perfect time to sign up if
you sign up at the great courses plus
comm slash mindscape you can begin with
a free trial
that's t-h-e great courses PL us calm /
- Cape start learning a whole bunch of
new things today
and one of the things that von Neumann
proved I'm not gonna get exactly the
theorem correctly but you know a game
like poker does have an optimal strategy
right it has a strategy where in
principle if you played this way no one
else would consistently beat you but no
one knows what that is right so we have
on the one hand the sort of Mathieu
problem of in one situation what should
you do if you were perfectly rational
and then we have the psychology problem
of can I bring myself to be perfectly
rational in this situation and what how
do you balance trying to learn those two
things yeah it's a it's a it's a
difficult thing to balance and I I don't
think that I don't think we're there yet
I don't know when we'll be there yet you
know one of the things that I love is
that to this day you know von Neumann
was so far ahead of his time but to this
day poker hasn't been solved but go has
been solved so many things have and
poker actually talked to some AI
researchers while I was researching the
book to get a sense of what they were
thinking and I had no idea I knew that
there were eight eye teams working on No
Limit Hold'em but I didn't know that
poker was actually kind of the paragon
of AI problems it was what people used
to test a eyes against you to try to see
you know how does this work and even
when they can get something close it
breaks down multi-way against many
people because as you were saying you
know there is this problem of how
rational do I want to be there's a
constantly moving rationality because
it's it's different to say I can't be
exploited and to say I'm going to win
right you you you want to play that so
if you know who you're playing against
the best strategy for you is not the
game theoretical optimal strategy
because you want to be exploiting the
weaknesses and the people you're playing
against absolutely absolutely but if
you're playing against someone who's
also very good and who understands that
then they might start exploiting you in
turn and you just have this constant
dance back and forth and then you start
thinking oh did they do this
so that
I would start exploiting them because
they knew I would so that they then they
could put me in this horrible situation
where they're going to counter exploit
me much worse right and it's just this
constant iterative analysis that's why
it's so human that's why it's so
difficult that's why it's so fascinating
and beautiful in the end and the
particular way that we failed to be
rational at the poker table is called
going on tilt right when something
happens to you and you you you know the
poker players know that sometimes you're
not at your best and I actually I think
even though I'm a big fan of poker and
I've read lots of books about it yours
might have been the first book that
pointed out you can go on tilt in a
positive way like things are going too
well for you and you become to think
that you're a genius as well as things
are going terrible and you just become
bitter yeah absolutely people people do
tend to think of tilts in a negative way
and I think the reason that I was able
to or that I thought of it in a much
broader way is that because my
background isn't just decision-making my
my advisor in graduate school was Walter
Mischel who people might know as the
marshmallow guy he was the man who had
the big marshmallow studies how long can
you wait for a marshmallow yeah and he
followed these preschool kids for
decades and showed that the amount of
time that they waited actually predicted
a lot of other things in life and he
called this delay of gratification and I
was Walter's last grad student and I had
a chance to work with some of the old
Bing students and to learn a lot about
what self control looks like and what
emotion looks like and what tilt even
though I didn't know the word tilt at
the time it's a beautiful word right
sure we I feel like we should use it in
every context it's so good and it can be
it's so evocative and it can be used in
as every single part of speech which I
love it's a perfect four-letter word but
but anyhow after that ode to the word
toast
I saw that it could actually that that
emotionality could be from a very
positive source it's not that the kids
were mad at the marshmallow or whatever
it was they wanted it was wonderful they
craved it it was a very positive emotion
but it impaired their thinking it
impaired their decision-making because
they were in such a excited state so
when I learned to the notion of tilt I
was already looking to see oh well I
know that emotions can actually be
positive and negative and if it's an
emotion and if it's an emotion that's
incidental rather than central to this
decision then it's going to make me less
rational and then it's going to make me
take a decision make kind of make a
judgement that I wouldn't otherwise make
because I'm relying on an emotion that
has nothing to do with it and so in
poker when most people think don't they
think oh the angry guy you know it's a
person who's losing and who's just
getting mad at everyone and who's fuming
and who just says Oh fine you know you
can't believe me around anymore watch
this but there's also the player who's
winning and who becomes who thinks this
is amazing like I can do no wrong as you
said I'm a genius
people always become geniuses when
they're winning oh yeah I mean it's just
it's crazy they just suddenly they know
everything and so if you're making
decisions because you think you're on a
roll or if you're making decisions
because you feel like you're owed the
chips because everything's just going
your way and so you say oh I'm just
gonna call with these two cards because
I'm hitting everything if you start
making decisions like that you're also
on tilt because you're also no longer
thinking through things in a rational
way and you're letting completely
incidental things color how you're
processing the current situation just
like probability doesn't have a memory
your stack of poker chips doesn't have a
memory it doesn't know you know that
that you've just won a hundred big
blinds there's no moment ever it is
exactly exactly they're just chips and
we just we love and viewing all sorts of
things with
personality and with meaning and with
intention but so it's just noise it's
just you know it's just stuff that does
not care about us it has no emotions it
has no memory
it doesn't care whether we're winning or
losing you know the deck doesn't care
it's gonna be the deck and but but
nevertheless I mean agree with all of
these things and yet I like you and
everyone else in the world who has
played poker has these experiences where
immediately after you do something you
or at least 10 seconds after you know
like wow that was a really irrational
thing to do right and you can know what
the rational thing to do is and yet you
don't do it and I guess my two questions
very very tiny questions you can I'm
sure you can answer very quickly number
one why does that does that happen do we
do we do things that you know part of
our brain certainly knows is irrational
and number two are there you know
practical strategies that you learn from
poker or from this journey you were on
for doing that a little bit less yeah
there's a big difference between theory
and execution and there are a lot of
steps in between so I found I find
myself still you know many many times I
can see myself from the outside I know
what the correct move is and I don't
make it because usually it's an
emotional reason I'm scared you know I
don't think it's going to work I don't
want to lose a lot of chips I don't want
to take on the risk I'm feeling
risk-averse or I'm feeling very risk
seeking and even though I know I should
fold and I know the correct decision
here is that I don't have the best cards
I'm just mad at this person you know
they're just rubbing me the wrong way
and I want to do what anyone so I do it
and right away I say oh my god I should
I know I should fold right now so it
happens in both directions and usually
it's an emotional reason and sometimes
it's also an execution problem where you
just you theoretically know but you
don't trust yourself enough and so in
poker and I think this is true
everywhere in life if you're not feeling
it it's not going to work
his people can see that they can sense
weakness they can sense hesitation they
can sense when you're bluffing in a
sense even if you're not bluffing so in
a negotiation if you say well you know I
want to raise but they can see that
you're really scared and if you're
scared of saying that and that you're
not gonna walk away and you're not going
to get that raise yeah and it's it's
something where there's there's this
there's a disconnect between what you
know you should do what you actually do
and then if you do it and that
disconnect is still there it's still not
going to work so you need to have
everything be in sync and that's
difficult so I think the way that one
does that is first through practice so
you have to just do it over and over and
over people who study too much theory of
anything whether it's in poker or in
some other in some other arena and don't
actually practice don't actually do
these things don't actually you know put
themselves out there and play hands
whether it's actual hands or
metaphorical hands without that practice
you're not going to be able to get
comfortable you're not going to be able
to execute under pressure what you're
trying to do is get it into that part of
your brain where it becomes almost
instinct where it becomes something
that's easy for you to do it's like it's
like when you're learning any new skill
think about you know something like well
this is a horrible example for me
because I don't know how to drive but
think about what I imagine most people
that at the beginning you know you're
really you have to try to coordinate
everything everything is kind of a
little scary
you're really have to pay attention to
everything and then at some point it all
goes on autopilot so to speak and you
things become much easier and then you
can also start executing things that you
couldn't do before like
three-point turns which I still I'm not
quite sure what they are but I know
they're scary but this makes sense this
makes sense in sort of
you know Kahneman's distinction between
type system 1 and system 2 right where I
think it's that system 1 is all the
automated you know subconscious things
going on in system 2 is your conscious
cognition that takes a lot of brainpower
to focus on and so what you're saying is
what we can try to teach ourselves to do
is to move as many processes from system
2 into system 1 right make them
subconscious and then that leave system
2 with it's very precious finite amount
of brainpower to think about the
important cases that are not
automatically solved by our newly found
instincts exactly
exactly a lot of it comes down to that
and a lot of it comes down to realizing
when we need to put system to online
when I was just starting to play poker
it was really hard for me to execute any
sort of meaningful Bluffs because I was
just so worried about paying attention
to everything you know I and it's also
because I had a very good teacher who
would tell me you know I need you to pay
attention to the stack sizes I need you
to pay attention you know to how many
times this person has raised in the last
ten hands or hundred hands or whatever
just all of these things and I'm
thinking ah you know I can't even find
the poker room in the casino how am I
ever going to how am I ever going to
think about all of these things at once
and slowly slowly slowly you start
that's become second nature because
you're getting used to doing it and then
all of a sudden you can think you start
being able to think okay you know are
these the right cards to bluff with in
this situation is this the right time to
raise is this the right time to make the
move that still doesn't mean you're
going to be able to do it because you
still might be scared because you might
do it once and it doesn't work you get
caught and then you feel sheepish and
you don't want to try it again at war
you don't get caught it works and then
you become a little bit too optimistic
and start making mistakes in the other
direction and so it's you know you have
to keep doing it over and over and you
have to get to a point where it's
comfortable and where to mean one of the
things that actually really helped me
and this is very funny because I'm a
psychologist last math class I took was
in heist
school that's not my background at all I
was very nervous you know starting poker
that I would need advanced mathematics
um Eric told me you know no you don't
you'll be fine as long as you can you
know add subtract multiply divide you'll
be fine but so I always thought my edge
was going to be psychological which it
is however the thing that actually
helped me learn to be more confident in
executing Bluffs and executing moves in
figuring all of that out and actually
putting into practice what I knew I
should do in theory was working with
solvers and working with this highly
mathematical thing I don't need to
understand how to run Monte Carlo
simulations the computer can do it for
me but if I do it and if I understand
the inputs and understand what I'm
working with and then look at the output
and then try to reason through why you
know why does the computer say that I
should Bluff with this particular hand
with this particular card and you
suddenly start to see the logic behind
it see the thinking behind it and then
when you're playing it doesn't feel like
a bluff it feels like oh I know that I
should do this here with this card this
percent of the time I'm not bluffing I'm
actually just executing the strategy
that I should based on what I'm holding
based on what I'm seeing based on what
I'm doing of course it's not it's
nowhere in this pace especially for me
especially for someone you know who
isn't mathematically inclined but that
was a very surprising to me that a
mathematical tool actually helped me
psychologically be able to be more
confident about some of these situations
where I in the past couldn't execute
where I couldn't quite pull the trigger
it does make me wonder because I'm
wondering about you know again why we we
do have these failure modes or these
mistakes
Hahnemann talks I think a little bit
about how some of our heuristics and our
instincts have evolved for certain
reasons but it almost sounds like what
we should be aiming for at the poker
table is to remove emotions from our
decision-making process entirely right
to be to become Spock or data as much as
possible and maybe that is a difference
between playing poker and living our
lives absolutely absolutely but I
actually think that what we should
aspire to do is first of all I think we
should realize that we can't remove
emotions entirely because we're
emotional creatures we're human and it's
not always good it's not always the
right thing to do to remove emotion from
a situation there was a lot of work that
was done by Antonio Damasio
neuroscientist on something called the
Iowa gambling task I won't get into that
task because that task has a lot of
problems with it but it was since
replicated in other gambling
environments and he looked at people who
actually had cortical damage whose
brains did not process risk so they had
no risk aversion whatsoever and they
ended up not doing well they went broke
so people who just couldn't experience
the fear of risk at all went broke and
did not make good decisions and so
sometimes emotions are actually
important right sometimes emotions keep
us from going broke they're there for a
reason because they're central to the
decision so I think what we need to
learn is to actually be more mindful and
more self reflective and pay more
attention to ourselves as we play so
that we can one identify when we're
feeling an emotion to figure out what
the emotion is and where it's coming
from so that we can 99% of the time we
want to discard it and say okay emotion
I see you're here I'm gonna put you
aside I know I'm feeling you but you're
not important for my decision let me
just put you here and make my decision
without you and then that 1% say okay
you're actually telling me something
important maybe I should listen to you
you know maybe it is time for me to step
away from the table because I'm just not
capable of thinking clearly right now
because I'm too angry I can't control it
I can't actually put it aside or
whatever it is so I think it's a lot of
it is about learning to see those to see
if those pattern
those thought patterns those reaction
patterns in yourself so that you can
then just account for them and
acknowledge them and then put them aside
and make a decision without them let me
pause for a second to talk about policy
genius a wonderful online website that
makes it easy to understand how to buy
insurance you might not be thinking
right now about something like life
insurance or auto insurance home
insurance and even if you do think about
it it can be intimidating there's a lot
of red tape there's a lot of choices
there's a lot of terminology which maybe
you don't know policy genius makes it
easy they collect and compare quotes
from the top life insurance companies
all in one place so all you do is enter
some of your basic information and you
can get quotes for what it would cost
you to get different kinds of insurance
and then you can compare them yourselves
pick the one that you really like policy
genius will take care of all the
paperwork and red tape for free so if
you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to take care of everything so if you're
one of the many people looking to buy
life insurance right now but you're not
sure where to start
head to policy genius com policy genius
will find you the best rate they will
handle the process completely they'll
get you and your family protected and
hopefully give you one less thing to
worry about yeah and the idea of
bluffing is probably one of the ones one
of the regimes in poker where emotions
come in pretty strongly and I remember
being very impressed by when I first
appreciate it I think was fun women who
proved that the whatever the best
strategy is in a game like poker it's
going to be a mixed strategy where you
don't do the same thing every time in
exactly the same situation and that is
exactly the kind of thing human beings
are just not very good at judging and so
you have to be in a situation where you
know what the on average best play is
and yet not do it sometimes and I don't
know whether yeah there's probably some
mixture of bringing emotions into the
game because you want to be a little bit
of a daredevil but also suppressing the
wrong emotions in these kinds of times
absolutely absolutely and we are I mean
we are very bad at mixed strategies and
often times we think we're randomizing
that's a very popular term in poker
these days that you're randomizing your
strategy you know I'm 25% of the time I
do that so 75% I do that and we don't
normally it's very hard for humans to do
that and so what a lot of actually the
best players do is they have some sort
of randomizer so that they for instance
I know a lot of players look at a watch
when they look at where the second hand
is and they have you know because that's
they can look to see you know if it's
between you know 12 and 1 or 1 and 2 etc
then they have their randomizer and if
it happens at 10 times in a row they're
I'm doing the play that they don't
really want to be doing well so be it
because they just look at that and
that's what they're doing and that's
true randomization or as true as you can
get at a poker table but it's still
incredibly difficult and and yeah
emotion really does play into it that's
why we don't randomize correctly that's
why we don't mix well because we often
just say oh I know that I'm supposed to
do this whatever percent of the time I
feel like doing this right now is gonna
do it but I actually have a theory about
this cuz I know about that trick of
looking at your watch with the second
hand to randomize but we also know that
human beings are bad at feeling what
real random sequences are like and part
of me thinks that what we should be
aiming to do is not to be random but to
appear random we should try to give the
opponent's at the table the appearance
that we do something 30 percent of the
time whether or not it's actually that
way so I kind of think that we should
it's a it would actually be better just
a judge well I've done this the last
three times and I know that I should do
it only three out of four times so next
time with 100% probability I'm gonna do
the other thing I think that's really
smart when I was researching the biggest
bluff I met this man who's really
fascinating thinker whose name is Frank
Lantz
and he runs the gaming Center at NYU I
should sorry I should say that both
Antonio Damasio and Frank Lance our
previous mindscape
guests so ok excellent so I had a chance
to talk to Fran Franck Lance and he has
done a lot with game design and what he
told me is that actually a lot of people
when they're designing games they
designed the probabilities incorrectly
on purpose because they know that the
human mind doesn't experienced real
probabilities in a good way so they know
that players will get frustrated you
know if they're if it's really random
and they're just on a losing streak and
so they actually skew it they skew their
randomizer so it's not truly random and
one of the reasons he loves poker is
because you can't do that in poker and
poker where is the naturally random game
and so he thinks that it forces us to
acknowledge that and that it forces the
human mind to actually kind of take that
into account and to be just hit over the
head with it and deal with it and he
actually thinks that it's a perfectly
designed game but one that modern game
designers would never design because the
thing yeah people would players would
actually just rebel and say this is
rigged and if you think about it think
how many times people play poker online
and say this is rigged this could I keep
losing over and over because they don't
understand that true probabilities can
look like that and that sometimes yeah
you get quads four times in an hour on a
table and but and the flipside of that
is that you know we can say how poker is
a merciless teacher and makes you try to
be as rational as possible yet we both
know real poker players and some of them
are pretty darn emotional and convinced
that all the luck in the world goes
against them right we can we will not
name names I got you don't talk about
luck I got so damn lucky that Eric
Seidel was the person I wanted to coach
me and that he said yes because he is
just one of the calmest just most
even-keeled people you'll ever meet
he just he does not tilt and the fact
that he would just nip all of those bad
dot happen habits in the bud for me that
was so powerful
because I wanted to do the same thing
you know I would start telling him bad
beat stories and for non poker players
bad be stories are basically when you
should have won but you didn't someone
sucked out on you or we you know said
over said you know someone had higher
cards than you and just the world won
against you and you want to start
ranting and raving and the first time I
tried to do that he yelled at me I mean
it's very hard to imagine if you've ever
met Eric Seidel raising his voice but he
came as it was as close to a yell like
I've ever heard and he explained to me
that this was just a really really
horrible way of thinking that I should
not dwell on that because yeah that
happens that's just variance I can't
control the outcome and so it's a bad
mental habit and it's going to make me a
worse player and I think he's absolutely
right because if you keep dwelling on
the bad beats it's gonna affect your
decision that's gonna affect your
emotions I mean it's gonna make you a
less pleasant person to be around but it
also just actually affects how you
process hands and how you process
information and I'm so grateful to him
even though at the in the moment you
know I I was pretty upset and I wanted
to just let him you know have him listen
to me I'm so grateful to him because
these days you know I don't remember how
I bus tournaments most of the time
unless it was a very interesting hand I
don't even remember those hands because
all I remember is when did I make an
interesting decision you know when were
there interesting thought problems what
what went wrong or what went right
how could my decision improve not what
the outcome was and Eric would always
say you know I can listen to the hand I
want you to tell me the hand if you have
a question about it if there's something
interesting and he even so when we
discuss hands together
he doesn't care how it ended after after
my River decision was done he doesn't
care if I won or lost in fact he doesn't
even want to know that information is
totally irrelevant all he cares about
are the decision modes leading up to it
and I think that's so powerful and that
really it's very also it's very freeing
because if you just think that way
about everything not just poker it
really helps you I think let go of
things and just be much more even-keeled
person now I understand why Eric is such
just a Zen master well I think Zen
master is exactly the term I was gonna
bring up I mean it's almost monthly or
saintly this idea that the process and
what we do is what we should be focusing
our judgment on not the outcome I mean
in the real world the idea of being
results oriented sounds like a
compliment right but poker players use
it as an insult because you care about
what the result was not whether or not
you made the right decision absolutely
absolutely
and being results oriented is one of the
worst mistakes you can make as a poker
player because it's going to it's going
to stop you from improving because
you're going to take the wrong
information and you're going to draw the
wrong conclusions you know if a really
bad decision works out a few times
you're like oh I should always do this
because they always fold here and no you
just got very lucky you got lucky twice
and that that's all that happened you
made really really bad decisions right
and and so it's so important not to be
results-oriented
and it actually um it also keeps I think
one of the reasons that Eric has had the
longevity that he's had is because he's
been very savvy about managing his money
even when he's winning because he knows
what variance looks like he knows that
no matter how much he wins now that
doesn't mean he's going to keep winning
at the same rate so many players who
could have been great players just went
broke because they go on a hot streak
the variance is in their favor they make
a lot of money and then whoops they stop
winning but by that point they've
already spent it all right and and there
they go there goes their career so I
think that that's it's important not
just not to be results-oriented not just
when you're playing poker but to then
take that thinking in a broader way well
and that's a lesson where maybe slightly
less confidently but we can apply it to
broader questions of result out outcomes
and results in life right there are
people who you know do
take wild risks many of them fail we
never hear of them some of them do
really really well and in their minds
and in mine stress to the world there
are geniuses and could do no wrong but
if you you know if a million people flip
a bunch of coins some of them are gonna
get ten heads in a row absolutely
absolutely and then you know the ones
who are successful write books to
explain exactly why they were successful
and then other people try to do it
because you're choosing on the dependent
variable which you know you cannot do
not suppose you need to have exactly you
know you need to have all those other
cases okay well what about all the
companies that did everything you're
doing and failed or all the people who
did everything you're doing and failed
and it's so hard for us to think that
way we look at the success stories and
we want to an explanation we want
certainty we want a story we want a
narrative we want to know you know what
went what brought you from point A to
point B and it's so easy once the
success is there to supply the reasons
and this is very unlike academia or
journalism where the best people
inevitably rise to the top for reasons
of value and virtue absolutely and
podcasting also yes absolutely yeah you
were a trained psychologist and this was
I guess your pitch to Eric Seidel one of
the world's best poker players like
you're slightly bringing a slightly
different angle to this did it help did
being a trained psychologist you know
when you sit down at the table once you
know the basic mathematical formulas and
and probabilities were you able to
psychologize your fellow players a
little bit and was that a useful skill
absolutely I actually do think that
being an outsider more broadly but a
psychologist and a journalist really
helped me so the psychology part helped
me identify a lot of the things and a
lot of the dynamics that I was seeing
and so I had a framework within which to
work so that I knew you know I could not
just see the bias I could name the bias
I knew what was happening and it helped
me address it better
because I had this metacognitive
awareness that I think a lot of people
who are playing at the poker table don't
have simply because that's not their
background that's not their framework
that's not the way they think through
things but I think that that really
helped and also knowing you know how
people can tilt in a lot of different
ways helped me identify positive tilt
helped me identify all of these dynamics
so Walter Mischel my adviser he had this
theory that basically we we all only
exist within situational contexts and
we're different people in different
contexts and what you need to know in
order to figure out well what kind of a
person is this is to have something that
he called a behavioral signature for
them you know given that this happens
what happens then so he'd say something
like you know there's no such thing as a
person who's risk seeking there's a
person who's risk seeking in certain
environments but maybe in other
environments that person is very
risk-averse there's no such thing as a
person who's just sociable 100% of the
time you might be very extroverted you
know very outgoing love people but
believe me I will find that person with
whom you are not only not sociable but
you become ya know the the least
sociable person in the world I will find
that situation and so having that sort
of background and having that sort of
approach to people really helped me I
think identified dynamics at the table
that other people might have missed and
I actually use it a lot in the sense
that I talk to people I am I talk a lot
at the poker table not when I'm playing
when I'm in a hand I don't talk at all
but when I'm sitting you know I get to
know people I try to figure out you know
where are you coming from
why are you playing what's motivating
you I try to get at some of their inner
psychology because that helps me
understand them and that helps me
understand why they might make certain
decisions why they might make certain
plays I've gotten much better at it over
time in the beginning I was bad just
flat-out bad because I wasn't quite sure
what I was looking for and I real and I
didn't know poker and so I lacked part
of that context but I think over time I
got much better and then the journalist
part
me I think was incredibly helpful
because I'm used to listening I'm used
to being in the background and just
letting people tell me their stories and
at the poker table it's so valuable not
to have your own you go table and to
just look at everyone else and let them
tell you what what their stories are I
think that's one of the things that
actually is my biggest edge is that I
try to keep my ego out of it well one of
the great things about your book I think
is that you seem to delight you take it
a special pleasure in talking about your
failures but that's what education all
right - the rest of us and one of them
was that you know early on in the career
you would make what I this may be this
is a term of art in psychology but you
called thin slice judgments where
basically judging someone of their
appearances and leaping to a conclusion
too quickly and ignoring contrary
signals so that's another thing the
banker I guess teaches us to be better
at oh absolutely
and yes this is a term of art of art in
psychology where you use a thin slice of
someone to then just make a judgement
about everything and there are so many
stories I could tell you about poker but
usually they involve guys and tank tops
and with a big biceps and tattoos I mean
that's usually and usually facial hair -
that's how a lot of these stories start
but also or little ladies right I mean
they're ladies yes that - that - or
little old ladies and those are kind of
the two strongest but boy was I wrong
again so many instances where I just saw
a guy like that I'm like he's a bully
he's gonna be like a total poker bro
he's gonna be trying to and a lot of
times there are no there's normal
players or sometimes they're even very
tight and like they they aren't
aggressive at all and if they're
aggressive you have to be really careful
and the little old ladies you know even
though that they think you think that
they're your best friend and that
they're harmless and that they're so
nice and sweet and wonderful if they're
good poker players and a lot of them are
they will then throw that right back at
you and there's no female solidarity
know if they'll be telling you that
you're a sweet young darling while
they're counting your chips in their
stack right exactly exactly I mean
there's a saying in poker there are no
friends at the poker table and it's so
easy to forget it I mean I've forgotten
it so many times I still sometimes
forget it because you know I don't wanna
be friends yeah where you can't possibly
be bluffing me I mean we were having
such well Jennifer I both like playing
poker but we won't play at the same
table in the casino together that's just
it's just asking for trouble absolutely
absolutely I think that that's a very
wise policy I hope you're never at a
table in the tournament together there
have been some interesting situations
with I don't know if you know the
Greenwood Brothers salmon Luke um they
are identical twins
and sometimes they're see and they're
both high stakes tournament players both
really nice guys really ethic oh there
there's never been any hint of anything
untoward between the two of them but
it's awkward right you're sitting right
next to you right that's a good twin
you're like okay I'm gonna have to bluff
you because that's what's going on and
they do they do not soft play each other
sometimes they it's just vicious when
you watch them on a TV table or you're
like well one of the one of the themes
in your book that's relevant to this is
you're sort of you have a search for the
right metaphor to bring to your
adventure as a poker player like you
started off I forget what there was like
you were an army general and then you
were a jazz musician and a detective and
then eventually a storyteller right I
mean you you yes you realize that and
this was in your wheelhouse like when
you look at these people who you're
playing with telling an inner story
about who they are and and more
specifically telling a story about that
particular hand and the actions they
took in it was very helpful in deciding
how to respond absolutely you're so
right you know I really I mean I tried
on so many hats as I went on this
journey and it was it was so funny to
realize that at the end of the day
storytelling which is what I've always
done is the thing that conserved me
best I mean sometimes you have to you
realize that the tools you already have
are the ones that that really do work
incredibly well and this was actually an
insight that I got from Phil Gelfand who
is also just this wonderful poker player
great guy who spent a lot of time
working with me as well and at some
point you know he told me to try to use
what I already know to try to use my
storytelling skills and when he said
that that actually made something click
because I realized you know everyone
does tell stories at the poker table
every single action is part of a
narrative and that helps you when you're
thinking about how other people play it
helps you analyze it because you're not
trying to think okay you know the
probability of him you know blah blah
blah is X because as we've already
talked about most people aren't rational
aren't playing in such a very strict
game theoretical way they're human and
they're trying to tell you a story so
you look for inconsistencies you look
for what they've said you look for you
know just does everything add up or not
and it also helps you play better
because you start thinking okay does my
story make sense and how what's the
story I want to tell and how do I tell
it from the beginning it helps you lay
out your plan of attack it helps you lay
out your strategy before you make the
first move
because you have to think through the
whole story you have to think through
the whole narrative and like with any
story you have to be willing to change
so sometimes you're writing and you
realize that your outline was wrong
right that what you thought was going to
happen in this piece or in this book
isn't what's happening and then you have
to reevaluate and I think that that kind
of flexibility is also very important in
poker because you could have the story
the outline the idea forehand you know
what's going to happen and then the
information just changes drastically and
you need to be willing to then scrap it
and say okay well what was the story I
was telling how does this new
information fit into it and can I adjust
it or not and sometimes the answer is
now
and that's when you know okay I need to
give up yeah this is not a story that's
gonna end I remember when I started
playing poker one of the dumbest things
that I would do was I would you know 20
minutes or half an hour had gone by and
I had not bluffed at all so I would
decide before the hand started that I
was gonna Bluff this hand and that's
just not good because I mean if you
learn a little bit you realize there are
good places to do that kind of thing in
bad places and you have to be able to
adapt to that story in real time another
thing that human beings are just bad at
right like we don't make a plan and you
know bullheaded Lee go forward with the
plan absolutely absolutely we tend to
not always be the most flexible
creatures and we we often don't like
reacting to to new things and new
developments and new circumstances once
again I think it's that aversion to
uncertainty you know we we have a game
plan and we want to follow the game plan
don't try to tell me the game plan has
changed
I prepared for this game and it's a it's
a skill I think it's something that we
can all learn we can all be better at I
mean it's something that I am still
working on every day I think all of
these elements that you learn in poker
are things that you just have to keep
working on and I think the moment that
you say I've mastered this is actually
the moment you should be really scared
because none of these are things that I
think ever can be mastered fully well we
should give our listeners who are either
current or potential poker players some
tangible advice that they can use to
improve their games I was thinking you
can give whatever advice you think is
most interesting but I was going to ask
about tells about the idea that
something someone says or does or
gestures or facial expressions at the
poker table can give away whether
they're strong or weak or bluffing or
telling the truth do you think is that a
real thing is that something that the
experts rely a lot on I think tells are
a real thing and I think that they're
underused that said I think that at the
highest levels there
are far fewer tells than at the lower
levels because the better a player is
the fewer tells there are and a lot of
times tells don't look like what you
think they're going to look like so a
lot of times people are looking at
things like oh you know did he fidget
did he do this did he do that oh he
looked up and I've heard that looking up
is a sign of lying and things like that
like just gestures and very specific
things most of the time those are too
noisy because in order for a tell to
tell you anything it needs to be
something that's reliable and for that
you need a lot of observation and
frankly just don't have enough time at a
poker table to get enough instances to
know whether something is actually a
towel or noise but the way that tells I
think work much better is if you start
looking at deviations from behavior so
just pay attention I mean my my number
one piece of advice is pay attention to
all of the players it's really hard if
you're sitting at a full table so start
with the two players to your left
because those are the players that
you'll be playing with most often
because you are the button when they're
the blinds and so you'll just
automatically be in pots with them more
often than with other players at the
table and just watch them and look how
are they sitting how are they acting
normally when they're not playing how
are they acting in a hand and try to get
all of the data that you can so whatever
hand goes to show down whenever you
actually see what they had think back
through how they acted and how they
played that hand you know were they
bluffing or not because you have some
concrete evidence and then you can
actually start drawing some sort of some
sort of vague connection and then what
you want to be looking for is any
deviations from how they normally behave
so if they're normally sitting in one
way and then suddenly their posture has
shifted it might shift differently for
every single
person and so that a shift in posture in
and of itself if someone suddenly
sitting more still or someone's more
moving more that doesn't mean they're
bluffing or not bluffing what about this
specific person you know have they acted
this way before and if not you know try
to figure out what does it mean based on
the information you have and even then
be careful that's a hard thing if
someone does something very much out of
character it could because they're
either really weak or really strong it's
just that they're not in a crate exactly
that's that's why I said try to look at
showdowns
you know try to see if that happens when
they show a hand down and you see were
they strong or were they weak but like I
said even then be careful because that
should not be the thing on which you
base your decision it should be kind of
the drop in the bucket if you need more
information so I try not to have it tell
me the thing that I rely on the most
under rare circumstances people have
tells that are real so I had I once
played with a guy who when he was weak
you could just tell his whole posture
just shifted and it was it was so funny
and I just I was so sad when we were
moved to different tables because I
loved playing with him that's rare it's
more like the tiebreaker I mean you
still gotta like figure out what your
percentages are and exactly exactly a
tiebreaker is a wonderful way of looking
at it but I do I mean I do think it's
important to pay attention to help
people are acting because sometimes you
also pick up on cues that you don't even
realize you're picking up on okay but
also and also I mean the the the
exhortation to pay attention is very
crucial because over and above the tells
right you're building up a model of this
person you know how they act in
different circumstances and it it might
have it might be completely based on
their actions not on their facial
expressions their actions in the sense
of what their bets and raises are and
stuff like that but that's people are
different and that's kind of crucial
absolutely absolutely
and then one of the other things that I
write about in the book that I won't
to detail now but that I think is
fascinating is that paying attention to
people's hands can actually be one of
the physical things that is the most
telling so people tend to move
differently tend to move their hands
differently when their different degrees
of strong I think that's really
interesting so if you're one of your
goals anyway at the beginning the
project was not just to win hundreds of
thousands of dollars in poker
tournaments but to learn to be a better
thinker and reasoner and so forth
did it work is the rest of your life
affected by your the training you have
in poker and can other people you think
improve their mental game by practicing
at the poker tables absolutely
absolutely I mean my I think my thinking
has become so much stronger just around
everything and I just I feel a
difference in how I approach situations
you know how I break them down in my
ability to really try to gauge the
quality of a decision without looking at
the outcome without thinking about the
outcome that's not something that I was
good at before and I mean sometimes it's
still really difficult to think that way
but at least I try I've become much
better at identifying my emotions I
think I've become a much stronger person
because I've had to confront a lot of
the kind of internal issues I've had
that would make me much more passive at
a poker table that would make me folds
that would make me kind of play in a
suboptimal way because I've had to
confront it in poker I think that has
made me more able to confront it in my
personal life
so I've you know had some negotiations
where I was able to get more money than
I otherwise would for instance like a
very practical thing I'm out of it that
was only because I was thinking in these
poker terms and I think especially right
now with you know everything going on in
the world the fact that I think poker
has really made me realize and try to
internalize a lot of the tenets of
Stoicism that I'd studied as an
undergrad but never really under
stood what what it meant I think that
that's really served me well you know
the idea of controlling what you can and
focusing on those things that you can
control and then letting go of the
things that you can't realizing you know
the world is going to happen bad things
are going to happen good things are
going to happen just things are going to
happen I can't control them so let me
focus on the things that are actually
within my power let me work on honing my
skills in the areas where they're
actually going to be helpful the quality
of my decision process the quality of my
emotional reactions of the way that I
think and respond and the outside world
well I can't control that so let me not
expend my emotional energy let me not
expend my mental space trying to worry
about it too much
yeah no I think that's a super valuable
lesson but I you know it brings me back
to something that I said before but I'll
raise it again because there are some
poker players that seem to live up to
that ideal of sort of zen-like
detachment and then you you found in
Eric Seidel a mentor maybe Dan
Harrington who you also talk to for the
book is like that but there's a lot of
very successful poker players who just
seem like crazy thrill-seekers in some
way right and even if they win the
million dollars they they lose a buck or
at the next day so there's clearly some
weird balance give and take or maybe
it's just some bility to turn on and
turn off that irrational thrill-seeking
that that you need to be able to say you
know what I have a really bad hand but I
think I can force this push person to
fold so I'm just going to make a crazy
bluff and that's that I don't know
whether as unliked attachment is the
right attitude to bring to that no I I
think I think that's a very valid point
and I think I think that if you're the
kind of player who knows exactly why
you're running a crazy bluff and you're
doing it with a very logical approach I
mean even an Eric Seidel or Dan
Harrington perfectly capable of
executing an insane bluff yeah in the
right moment against the right person
they don't just do it
they feel like this is the moment to
Bluff they don't do it for irrational
reasons and I do think that a lot of
players who are really great poker
players and they're not so great at life
they're capable of doing that at the
poker player at the poker table but then
they just they turn it off no they don't
they don't apply it to any other context
I talked earlier about kind of this
metacognitive awareness well they don't
have it no for them they can do it at
the poker table and then they just let
it all go somewhere else someone else
who I met during the process of writing
this book who unfortunately died as I
was writing it was one of Eric's mentors
Paul mcgrill known as X 22 and X is a
perfect example of someone who was
brilliant at games horrible in life knew
it and it was still the case he couldn't
quite get over it because human beings
are complicated messes of different
little sub processes right we're not
unified singular cod Cheetos or whatever
we have different parts to ourselves
that we bring to different situations
exactly where we're complex were its
shades of grey it's not black and white
there's a lot of uncertainty there's a
lot of unknown and there's just there's
a lot of complexity there and I think
that that's a wonderful thing yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely we should
celebrate it but so to finish up I mean
I'm not even sure if it's a question
just a statement that maybe you can
expand upon but aside from poker and
aside from rationality and and emotions
and bringing them into line and things
like that your book is also a story
about just taking a wild leap into
learning something not as a young kid
that is a completely different world
right you know it's it's a testament to
the excitement and the potential
downfalls sometimes of just throwing
yourself wholeheartedly into something
that is pretty alien I mean what are
your what are your feelings about that
having done it you know you tell these
great stories about going on helicopters
in Monte Carlo and
and casinos in Macau and so forth yeah I
mean I think that's absolutely true it
was a huge leap and it just scared the
crap out of me in every single way both
because I took an established career and
said I'm gonna put you on hold and I'm
gonna just go into this crazy world and
so many people I respected told me I was
insane they said you know you can't stop
writing regularly for The New Yorker
everyone's gonna forget your name
they're gonna forget who you are
you need to be in front of people you
need to be you know you need you need to
build the momentum of your career you
need to build your reputation you can't
do this other people would say well if
you're gonna you know do pull a George
Plimpton and go all experiential
journalism why poker you I mean it's
gambling it's horrible there's you know
awful thing why go into that world and
so I had a lot of these thoughts in the
back of my mind I thought you know this
might be a terrible mistake
and I was really scared and then I was
really scared and also to write this
book because I'm not a first-person
journalist you know normally I only
write about other people I don't use I I
don't remember the last time I used I
and a piece I wrote in this book was
going to be completely different and so
that was also a huge leap of faith for
me I didn't know if I'd be able to pull
it off I don't know I didn't know if
people would like it I didn't know if
people would like my voice I didn't know
what my voice was in that context so all
of it was really scary and in a weird
way that's how I knew it was something I
really wanted to do because the way that
I've actually approached a lot of my
life is that new things should be scary
and if you're not scared that means that
you're not challenging yourself enough
that means that you're just not going to
grow because you're staying too much in
your comfort zone and I've done a few
you know crazy career things in my life
no I moved to New York with just no
money whatsoever I became a bartender I
took a job for $23,000 a year in New
York so that I could write and a lot of
these things didn't quite work out I
think I went through like five jobs in
my first
out of college but I think and it was
always scary but I always thought you
know what let me do it
and I'm very very lucky in the sense
that even though I don't come from a
wealthy family at all I mean I grew up
just in a poor family and now they're
nicely middle-class but you know we came
from the Soviet Union we had nothing we
were just political refugees and so I
never it wasn't like my parents would
say oh don't worry you know we'll pay
your rent they couldn't they would love
to but they couldn't but they are the
most supportive loving people and
they've always had my back and so I knew
that like if [ __ ] hit the fan I could
always just go home right I could always
just I had parents who were there and
you know they said we can't pay your
rent but you can come move back in with
us you know we can't give you this but
we love you and we support you and the
reason we moved to this country is so
that you could do whatever you wanted
not so that you'd be a doctor or a
lawyer
my sister is already a doctor so amazing
to do that but but so that you could do
what you want to do and I think I don't
want to underestimate and understate how
important that was knowing that I had
that emotional backing I think it made
me much more able to take risks that not
everyone has the luxury of taking yeah I
mean it's a it's a once again a mixed
strategy right I mean is a little bit of
a balance between being responsible
understanding if there is a back-up plan
and so forth but not just being
complacent not just doing the same thing
over and over again I think it's it's
too easy to be either a crazy gambler or
a stodgy stick-in-the-mud and you know
you think things interesting without
inviting disaster is a tricky balance
and worth trying worth aiming for
absolutely absolutely
I think that's if I can keep meeting
that goal throughout my life I think it
will be a life well-lived in a lot of
ways me too and I think the book is a
great success and people who read it
will will get that feeling the
excitement will come across so Maria
konnikova thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast
thank you so much for having me Sean
[Music]